vendhya took to snapchat to share this  story well we just got this bond now I'm  trying to buy a lot of gift card now  there's some certain specific things you  have to do when it comes to buying gift  cards there's some certain limits and  some things which is understandable okay  cool so I'll take a less amount whatever  but the way that was helping us I think  she's a huge fan of our skin tone not at  all extremely we're not trying to help  us at all saying that we could buy the  gift cards and then throwing my wallet  through your wallet  she literally she threw your Wiley's  then and she was like you can't afford  this is how she look I'm good long story  short there's so much progress to be  done in our world et has reached out to  the grocery store chain where zendaya  claims this happened for comment  yo shout out to the manager for coming  and helping okay gotta got my gift